on est très content de les réunir ce
soir le monde municipal on a
l'impression de prendre place encore
plus grande dans cette campagne
électorale dans la vie politique en
général au Québec Valérie plante merci
d'être là à Québec très plaisir Bruno
marchand merci d'être chez vous
c'est très gentil première question bon
on a dit ils seront les véritables chefs
et chef de l'opposition
première réaction à ça c'est quand même
vous avez quand même un pouvoir
important quand vous mettez ensemble
Montréal Québec là ils doivent écouter
derrière ici ils doivent écouter mais
nous on va le faire de façon
constructive donc si je réponds à votre
question est-ce qu'on va être
l'opposition au Québec la réponse est
non nous ce qu'on veut c'est être de
véritables partenaires avec le prochain
gouvernement puis c'est pas pour rien
qu'on a mis des idées ou si novatrices
et vraiment connecté au terrain comme le
pactovaire j'imagine qu'on aura la
chance d'en reparler mais c'est ça qu'on
souhaite nous oui on veut se faire
entendre mais on va le faire
vous donne les municipalités demandent 2
milliards par année 5 ans c'est 10
milliards tout le logo était pas très
chaud à l'idée mais il devient de plus
en plus chaud
de toute façon l'enjeu c'est ce que
c'est ça qu'on veut pas si on attend ça
va coûter pareil ça va juste coûter plus
cher que 2 milliards quand est arrivé
les inondations à Montréal ce qui arrive
avec Fiona nécessairement faut réparer
et réparer c'est nécessairement payer
plus parce qu'on le fait en urgence
parce qu'on le fait ça en planification
parce qu'on le fait en ayant pas le
choix alors ce qu'on dit au gouvernement
c'est si on ne fait pas maintenant en
prévision de ce que ça en vient parce
que ça s'en vient on est trois prises
mortes
les les réparations au bon moment ça va
coûter moins cher que de le faire en
urgence mais on veut aussi éviter des
drames humains c'est parce que les gens
vivent en ce moment-là puis je pense à
oser de la Madeleine mais l'île de
Montréal c'est une île donc toute la
question des
du fleuve donc d'adapter nos routes nos
infrastructures d'eau nos berges c'est
nécessaire pour éviter le plus possible
des drames humains parce que les
changements climatiques malheureusement
vont toujours être plus fréquents et
plus fort qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
pour vos villes le 2 milliards récurrent
ça servira à quoi Montréal ça servir à
quoi Québec vous faites quoi avec cette
somme là très très concret justement
entre autres toutes nos
ordonnances qu'elles sont
particulièrement basses on voit que
quand il y a beaucoup d'eau ben ça ça se
remplit notre réseau de métro notre
réseau d'acqueduc puis j'ai envie de
vous parler d'un projet qui s'appelle
l'usine de donation nous on met 700
millions de dollars des morialet
montréalaise pour faire en sorte que
l'eau est plus propre une fois qu'on la
rejette dans le fleuve vers Québec alors
c'est un projet qui va contribuer au
Québec
tellement plus propre c'est un projet
qui va profiter à tout le Québec qui
protège le fleuve Saint-Laurent mais
c'est pas normal que ça soit seulement
les morialets qui payent la facture donc
même chose des choses très concrètes
vous dites
on avait pas ça avant qu'est-ce qu'on
faisait on enfoucine aux déchets
historiquement certains les brûlaient à
Québec on avait une zone on inspirait
nos déchets pour se dire c'est comme ça
on les voit plus nos déchets donc on est
heureux on s'est aperçu qu'en
environnementalement parlant ça avait
pas de sens Québec a construit une usine
de biométhanisation pour faire de
l'énergie avec les déchets compostables
on met ça en place cet automne
nécessairement il y a un coût pour la
ville oui on répond à des normes
gouvernementales oui il faut être
meilleur à gérer nos déchets mais si le
gouvernement nous tient pas juste cette
usine là c'est 20 à 25 millions dans le
budget de fonctionnement chaque année de
plus qu'on avait pas avant alors si le
gouvernement nous tient pas c'est où
qu'on le prend dans la poche des
citoyens on veut pas ça mais pourquoi le
oui n'est pas arrivé si rapidement parce
que Monsieur le goût n'a pas dit oui je
le rappelle aux gens qui nous écoutent
pourquoi parce que ça a l'air très
concrète évident même quand vous écoute
c'est extrêmement concret c'est des
solutions terrain par exemple à Montréal
on fait des parcs bleus c'est à dire que
quand il est grosse pluie diluvienne
c'est tellement dur pour les égouts
qu'on a commencé à faire des parcs qui
servent d'éponge c'est très concrètes ça
coûte pas si cher que ça alors nous on
arrive des propositions et là ce qu'on
veut c'est pas pour rien que les villes
on s'est mis ensemble les 10 plus
grandes villes du Québec pour dire NON
NON dans ce cette élection là les villes
doivent être entendues mais aussi des
solutions durables pour la 35 écologique
puis adapté alors moi je le vois comme
une opportunité et puis je suis très
fière de cette solidarité là entre les
villes les municipalités et les villes
vous êtes côte à côte mais vous
travaillez ensemble vous avez
on va les souper ensemble pour vous dire
on va se faire ensemble on s'entend bien
mais deux il y a une nécessité
absolument il y a nécessité c'est c'est
Valérie et moi mais c'est aussi Stéphane
Boyer c'est Catherine Fournier c'est
c'est France Bélize c'est c'est des
mères qui fasse au même réalité et
savez-vous quoi quand on regarde les
thèmes de campagne cette année il y a
jamais eu autant de thèmes liés au
municipal qui en a eu dans les élections
précédentes là pensez à l'environnement
mais aller plus loin que ça pensez à la
mobilité penser au transport
l'habitation logement social pas
beaucoup encore dernier point là-dessus
vous le faites du genre de campagne
électorale
vous voulez qui arrive quoi avec ça que
les gens disent bon telle partie en
barque sur le pacte vert de ma
municipalité donc ils auront mon vote là
dans ce côté
nous on dirait jamais aux citoyens pour
qu'il voter ça là on est d'accord que
c'est aussi citoyen qui est
l'intelligence de dire pour qui vote en
fonction du député qui veut en fonction
du parti auquel il croit ça c'est
fondamental de respecter l'intelligence
citoyenne mais on a le devoir de dire un
autre monde voici ce que comme ville est
important parce que pour réparer pour
entretenir mais aussi assouvir les
besoins des citoyens qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire il faut être capable de le
dire il faut être capable d'avoir un
gouvernement qui s'engage après ça aux
citoyens de décider puis la raison pour
l'entrée aussi c'est qu'on veut
s'assurer que les nos citoyens
comprennent que si pour eux la transfert
écologique est importante qu'ils disent
que oui c'est qu'après ça ça retrouve
pas juste sur leur compte de taxe
foncière que on prend cette
responsabilité elle doit être partagée
c'est un choix de société je vous repose
la question que je vous posais au tout
début quand Montréal et Québec rame dans
même direction que vous le vouliez ou
non ça vous donne de pouvoir politique
et non absolument
quand les études seront publiées on est
rendu là quand les études seront
publiées si vous avez encore de grosses
réserves ou pires vous êtes contre ce
que le projet peut se faire sans votre
appui ben je pense que non je pense que
non
au gouvernement de décider monsieur LEGO
a raison de dire que c'est un choix
politique au final tout choix et
politique maintenant à lui démontrer sur
quoi il s'appuie pour dire je fais ce
choix là mais prenons juste un exemple
de ça les sorties d'autoroute elles vont
sortir à quelque part dans Québec on
peut pas dire faites-le où vous voulez
c'est pas important au Québec c'est
important que les gens tiens Sauveur
c'est important où les gens où ils vont
sortir si ça crée du trafic c'est pas
grave le mur de Québec il va fermer sa
boîte mais non on y est obligé de
travailler ensemble j'ai confiance que
le gouvernement s'il va de l'avant avec
son projet il va dire ben je m’entends
Québec pour faire en sorte que ça
respecte les volontés de la ville de
Québec des citoyens Québec
c'était ça mon message on peut pas faire
un projet de transport que je souhaite
absolument mais sans que Montréal soit
autour de la table parce qu'au final ça
se passe sur notre territoire
le projet est tombé plus le prochain à
quel moment il va avoir un vrai projet
pour les gens de l'Est de Montréal
l'impression que on a gagné du temps
mais ça va être éternel comme discussion
quand même je veux dire j'étais pas
contre le projet c'est vraiment le
tronçon dans le centre-ville où il y
avait pas d'acceptibilité sociale puis
moi je comprenais là les préoccupations
par contre quand j'ai pris le téléphone
pour parler que le premier ministre que
je lui dis c'est il y a un tronçon qui
marche celui dans l'est et là ce qu'on a
décidé de faire premièrement c'est que
la vie de Montréal on est autour de la
table alors c'est la Ville de Montréal
le MTQ gouvernement du Québec et la RTM
et on va partager on s'est donné
quelques mois mais cet automne on va
partager à quoi va ressembler nouveaux
projets et je suis extrêmement
enthousiaste par rapport à ça parce que
ce que je voulais c'est au tour de la
table bon
dynamique spécial qu'on a dans la région
de Québec que je me permets Patrice ici
qui est pas sûr pour le troisième lien
parce que c'est pas où ça va arriver
dans ce trajet
mais on a un membre de l'autre côté qui
lui en veut le maire Gilles Ollier de
Lévy en veut parce que c'est
probablement synonyme de développement
pour sa ville est-ce qu'il y a pas un
peu de sommes chez marchand de dire mais
allez-y oui c'est l'étalement il y a des
gens qui vont qui pourraient aller
rester dans le secteur de Beaumont puis
être aussi près du centre-ville que
quelqu'un
moi j'ai aucun problème à ce que le fait
que le maire de Lévy veuille développer
sa vie les vies pour moi c'est une ville
c'est
urbain c'est pas de l'étaler urbain mais
on a besoin de s'assurer qu'on s'en va
pas dans des terres agricoles de
Bellechasse développer de la du
résidentiel qui va faire en sorte que
les gens vont voir comme ça le moins de
transport l'autoroute et l'auto qui va
faire en sorte qu'on va amputer des
terres agricoles dont on a bien besoin
de se nourrir on va éloigner les chaînes
d'approvisionnement et on va se dire
comment ça nous légumes comment ça nous
frits viennent encore plus loin comment
ça ça coûte encore plus cher comment ça
surtout il y a un impact environnemental
encore plus grand on a présentement des
terres agricoles qu'on doit protéger que
les qui se développer pour moi c'est pas
un enjeu du tout tant mieux et monsieur
leoullier a raison maintenant si jamais
le gouvernement va de l'avant on parlait
de donner mais ça ça en est un exemple
comment il va faire pour ceinturer
l'étalement urbain comment il va faire
pour pas qu'on empiète agricole c'est
important pour tout le monde ici c'est
important
très bien la sécurité beaucoup de gens
ont l'impression c'est un problème de
Montréal
d'abord est-ce que ça vous êtes rassuré
par l'annonce qui avait été faite avant
le déclenchement
pour plus de policiers vous êtes encore
en demande vis-à-vis du gouvernement du
Québec c'est sûr que ça a été une
bouffée d'air frais là parce que ça va
nous permettre de d'augmenter les
effectifs parce que les policiers
policières puis moi je fais des
patrouilles avec eux puisqu'il me dit
c'est qu'il y a une fatigue puis ça je
le comprends mais je pense que ce qui
est important pour moi mais c'est à dire
que oui mais il y a aussi le roulement
il y a beaucoup de policiers qui s'en
vont à la retraite donc tout ce change
ces effectifs là quoi qu'ils doivent
être remplacés puis on veut également
pouvoir en ajouter en fonction des
différentes escouades mais de vous dire
aussi que dans ce 250 millions là ce qui
est important pour moi c'est à dire j'ai
des fonds pour la prévention une équipe
communiste qui sont les travailleurs
sociaux de la Ville de Montréal qui
enlèvent la pression pour les policiers
parce qu'on le sait de 30 à 40 % des
appels que reçoivent le SPVM sont liés
avec des problématiques souvent de santé
mentale ou de détresse alors il faut
pouvoir aider les policiers dans ce
travail-là donc est-ce que ça le fait du
bien oui est-ce que ça règle tout non
parce qu'en plus la sécurité urbaine
entre vous et moi l'on parle surtout de
l'augmentation de la violence armée à
Montréal mais on a vu quand même des cas
malheureusement de santé mentale qui ont
dégénéré que ce soit Québec à Montréal
à Québec est-ce que vous avez un
problème est-ce que ça s'en vient ou pas
ou ici c'est encore de penser que parce
que c'est à Montréal c'était à 300 km si
ça arrivera pas à Québec ça serait une
erreur majeure ça serait se mettre la
tête dans le sable comme on a fait des
fois durant pandémie en disant c'est en
Europe ça arrivera pas ici trois
semaines plus tard tu as rendu ici moi
nous on travaille avec l'idée que un il
faut avoir
un meilleur une meilleure façon de
travailler avec nos policiers les
groupes communautaires soutenir nos
policiers soutenir nos propres promenade
plus à travers de rue et faire en sorte
qu'on travaille mieux ensemble pour
faire en sorte que le problème que nous
avons pas présentement ou très peu par
rapport à Montréal mais on apprenne de
ce qui se vient à Montréal et qu'on
évite de se dire non c'est l'autre bout
de la 20 ça arrivera pas ici ça sera un
gars électorale est-ce que c'est juste
une question d'argent problème
d'itinérance notamment dont on parle
beaucoup en basse ville à Québec c'est
pas juste une question d'argent ça
commence par de la volonté l'itinérance
va atteindre l'itinérance zéro à Québec
puis on va l'atteindre pourquoi parce
que je me bats dure comme faire pour que
des politiciens notamment le maire de
Québec voilà mais aussi le scius mais
aussi le prochain ministre qui sera
responsable titulaire de ce ministère là
qu'on soit qu'on fasse une sortie
publique dès sa nomination qu'on dise on
s'engage à l'itinérance zéro on se donne
par exemple 10 ans voici les jalons
qu'on va atteindre et si on l'atteint
pas vous allez être capable de critiquer
il faut injecter tant on a besoin de
temps mais regardez l'eau de rivière
présentement qui est notre centre notre
plus gros centre qui accueille des
itinérants est à peu près exceptionnel à
80%, il y a 20% des unités des champs
qui sont pas fonctionnelles parce qu'il
manque d'argent oui on a besoin d'argent
mais ça commence par une question de
volonté ça commence par des politiciens
qui ont du courage qui acceptent de dire
mais vous me critiquerez vous me direz
que j'ai pas été assez bon on va
s'engager on va mettre notre tête sur le
bio c'est pas vrai qu'on va laisser ce
problème là aller madame plante sur
cette question-là aussi on a
l'impression quand on se balade à
Montréal que ça ne fait qu'augmenter la
pandémie là ça a été difficile on a vu
vraiment de la précarité a pris beaucoup
plus de place on a vu aussi à quel point
les refuges sont des organismes
communautaires étaient aboutissouf donc
nous des choses qu'on a demandé
gouvernement c'est de sortir de la
logique saisonnière ça c'est vraiment
important puis j'imagine qu'à Québec
dans les autres villes c'est la même
chose aussi pendant longtemps le
financement c'était oh l'été on en a
moins l'hiver ne plus on met des lits
d'urgence au final c'est quoi cette
logique là autour des itinéraires comme
si ils disparaissait pendant l'été puis
il y en avait plus pendant l'hiver faut
sortir de l'oeuf il faut avoir plus de
refuge et je suis à fait d'accord avec
Bruno faut de la volonté mais il faut
vraiment voir une
[Musique]
[Rires]
puis les endroits où lui a une position
qui est différent de la mienne on va
continuer mais oui de se réunir de
savoir si les préoccupations des grandes
villes parce que ce sont les précieuses
les préoccupations des gens du Québec
puis en fait j'ai envie de dire pour
nous c'est important à Montréal que à
l'umpy on a fait de la même chose c'est
parler de la fiscalité justement pour
sortir un peu de cette logique là où on
a l'impression que les villes sont
perçues comme des créatures de l'état du
gouvernement du Québec nous ce qu'on
mange c'est que de la même façon que
Québec a eu raison d'aller au fédéral
soutenu par les Québécois québécois se
dire on a plus de de responsabilités on
veut plus de pouvoir puis plus d'argent
c'est ça qu'on veut nous autres
participer
les façons légales mais la chicane
Québec Montréal
mais peut-être au football
participer axe Montréal Québec se
développe
enjeux qui sont des réalités différentes
mais on partage vraiment des objectifs
communs donc la transition écologique ça
se passe dans les villes dans nos rues
dans dans les caves de nos de nos
citoyens
merci merci